E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
o e-mail 61 o Russo Yuri Gagarin foi a
primeira pessoa a ir o espaço ele disse
vejo a terra ela é azul
e foi essa afirmação que ficou matutando
na minha adolescência
afirmação é essa transmitida pelo meu
professor de Geografia na quinta série
um irmão Marista o irmão Renato
e tem o hábito de subir burrows logo
cedo quando a paisagem lá embaixo está
coberto de nuvens e o céu lá em cima
está limpo e essa frase Gagarin vem à
mente
É nesse grupo de Garen o debaixo
daquelas nuvens que vejo vivinho pessoas
que se interagem de alguma forma
eu tive que completei 30 anos de idade
sai em busca da resposta para essa
pergunta que surgiu como será esse mundo
Azul esse mundo das nuvens assim
programei minha vida criando
oportunidades para viajar seja no Brasil
na América Latina na Ásia na Europa na
África e no oriente médio para me Expor
essas diferentes sociedades culturas
povos aprendendo o máximo que podia
convivendo com eles frequentando os seus
lares comendo suas comidas
escolhi modo de viagem que ofereciam uma
integração maior com o povo local essas
primeiras viagens foram e trem e carona
até de camelo a mais longa delas foi uma
viagem de bicicleta uma volta ao mundo
em 747 Dias atravessando 30 países
e
percorrendo 32 mil km
nela Descobri que esse é o melhor meio
de conhecer o mundo você viaja vai ser
das pessoas
a entrar em contato com rotina desses
povos a sensação de pertencimento que a
bicicleta proporciona é única
a bicicleta descobri que a gente não
precisa de muitas coisas ao nosso redor
que o essencial mesmo é ter sempre um
par de Havaianas
o e continua viajar com elas desde que
regressei dessa viagem em 2014 me
programo para viajar aproximadamente cem
Dias 90 a 100 dias por ano foi assim que
criei um estilo de vida para ser um
cidadão Global um Global thinkers o que
seria o que será um Global thinkers esse
conceito parte lá do processo da
globalização
o Global fim quem o pensamento global
que é o risco chama esse cidadão global
é aquele cara que sai em busca do
conhecimento Através de outros povos e
mais do que isso busca desenvolver
atitudes valores habilidades e ações
comprometidas com Esses povos claro
também com relação à igualdade à
democracia os direitos humanos EA
sustentabilidade serão Global fim é
reconhecer que você faz parte das forças
o imóvel uma sociedade não existe o
nosso e os outros parece fácil não é o
escritor português José Saramago
diz que o mais difícil não é viver com
as pessoas e difícil mesmo é
compreendê-las e essa Compreensão é a
busca contínua da vida de um Global
finca
E aí
e tem uma história que ilustra muito bem
isso que eu nunca me esqueço quando pela
pedalava na Malásia uma van parou
enquanto a consertar o pneu furado da
bicicleta era um grupo de indianos que
visitavam parentes que já viviam um
deles aparentando ser um tipo de um
líder daquele grupo disse a mim vocês lá
no Brasil são tão pobres assim não tem
dinheiro para o ônibus preciso sair aí
de bicicleta
aí ele disse a minha sem tome aqui vai
de ônibus agora até o teu próximo
destino
me deu o dinheiro equivalente r$ 200
hoje põe ou não continua de ônibus
continue pedalando
e esse é um exemplo E quanto a visão
sobre a pobreza o sucesso EA felicidade
pode ser algo muito relativo
Algum cara e ficar aqueles que
nacionalidades desiguais quanto mais
igual desigual uma sociedade mais
explícita a esse pensamento
trazendo isso para a academia EA
metáfora das camadas de cebola do
professor Dr Mike Edgar China essa
teoria é muito visado os estudos e
cultura organizacional diz que
culturalmente somos como uma casca de
cebola
é uma cebola na verdade né tirando essas
várias camadas que formam os seus Anéis
chega ao ponto essencial o centro que
ali está os nossos valores as nossas
regras nossos tabus questões que que
estão inseridas naquela sociedade né são
incontestáveis eu mesmo
são exemplos disso eu posso ser um
tremendo de um Global thinkers nós do
fundo sempre serei um cidadão
jaraguaense
e por isso pode interações que observava
e das quais participavam por é afora
pelo mundo
e sempre comparei com aqui venceu na
minha cidade
como as pessoas de se dirige a uma outra
como compartilho as vias o trânsito um
lugar da bicicleta nessa dinâmica os
preconceitos e todos nós temos
como é o cuidado com o meio ambiente e
ao mesmo tempo eu também amei
valorizando com obstáculos os problemas
que apresentavam a minha cidade né e
procurava toda hora nesse momento uma
conexão com que eu via por aí
bom e sabe que tem uma coisa muito
interessante que todas as idades dos
continentes as cidades menores nem todos
os conteúdos poderá fazer as menores em
algo em comum elas não gostam muito
diferente o professor gera Diamond da
Universidade da Califórnia fala muito
esse tipo de intercâmbio e ao longo de
suas obras o parte o Brasil é um país
não é muito chegada diferente não se
conforme dados do IBGE não chegaram por
cento e estrangeiros que vivem no Brasil
São Paulo que a nossa Metrópole tem
apenas dois por cento de estrangeiros
só por um comparativo
conforme a reportagem da revista Forbes
o estado da Califórnia por exemplo
possui 5 das cidades estados unidos com
maior número de estrangeiros isso não
percentual aí ao redor de 30 40 porcento
é uma essa integração internacional
brasileira é baixa a gente acaba tendo
uma sociedade mais provinciana
Ah e quanto mais aberto uma sociedade
quanto maior a sua interação com o mundo
mas Google Finger é o seu povo
é como se pode ver alguns países por
exemplo o Nepal EA Tailândia Eles
criaram uma interessante interseção
entre o que vem o do ocidente com as
suas raízes orientais um outro exemplo
no ocidente a Holanda
conforme o escritor Umberto Eco ele
disse que é o melhor país do mundo para
se viver né porque um país muito aberto
as diferenças mas o que podemos fazer
para que sejamos Global thinkers O que
podemos fazer a partir disso
a mudar a mentalidade
os ingleses passaram por esse processo
no seu período de colonização em 1920 a
Inglaterra de tinha 25 porcento
território de todo o globo
Oi e aí ó as músicas foram maior Império
que você tem na história Então como
Aquele caso do Senhor indiano que achou
que eu viajava de bicicleta porque não
tinha dinheiro para pagar o ônibus
temos que ter em mente que essa visão é
algo construído algo histórico algo
social essa visão se baseia é o nosso
centro que está embaixo das camadas de
cebola
mas também podemos mudar um pouco disso
Nós podemos
ser com o nosso passado né e deixar isso
para o passado em si e não pode podemos
mudar o nosso futuro perante é isso
podemos escolher um outro caminho claro
que esse ano nossas certezas com isso
também não estou pedindo para que
mudamos o nosso estilo de vida
vendemos nossas coisas né temos uma vida
aumento e ter uma vida nômade não isso
não tem também nada a ver com Global
Finger da mesma forma não é preciso
pisar em vários países para entender a
importância os valores e outras culturas
e Principalmente nesse mundo nesse mundo
atual um tanto acesso à informação o que
estou pedindo é tenhamos empatia é se
interessa e pelo outro né respondo as
diversidades se engaje com algo coletivo
se abra ao desconhecido
Aristóteles vice que nós somos seres
curiosos
Particularmente eu acredito que a
curiosidade que me move o ser E aí
a todos os dias quando Acordamos tem uma
nova chance de imaginar a terra azul de
Gagarin em um mergulharmos as nuvens
sobre o monte vamos ver o mundo as
diferenças como Pontes ou portões não
como obstáculos assim depois se descobre
que a clínica é diferente acaba sendo
igual Muito obrigado
E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]